President Trump taking his case for
border security to the American people
in week three of the shutdown stalemate
the president set to deliver his first
primetime oval office address tomorrow
night on what he's calling the quote
humanitarian and national security
crisis on our southern border and on
Thursday President Trump is heading to
McAllen Texas to survey the situation on
the ground and meet with immigration
officials the president also now saying
he's willing to compromise on building a
concrete wall and Trump isn't ruling out
declaring a national emergency if
Congress doesn't give him the necessary
funding they don't like concrete so
we'll give him steel steel is actually
more expensive than concrete but it'll
look beautiful and it's very strong it's
actually stronger we're looking at a
national emergency because we have a
national emergency just read the papers
it is national security it's a national
emergency
Democratic congressman Jerry Nadler says
he doubts the president will be truthful
in his address to the nation tomorrow
night the president has announced that
he's going to address the country
tomorrow night on the so-called crisis
at the border I expect the President to
lie to the American people why do we
expect this because he has been lying to
the American people and his spokespeople
continue like the American people and
Senator Lindsey Graham is slamming the
quote radical left for refusing to
negotiate with the GOP as long as the
radical left is in charge we're never
going to get anywhere
the president will compromise but he
will not capitulate so that's where at
I'm not going to negotiate with somebody
who calls the Border Patrol agents a
bunch of Nazis when they're trying to
defend the border against a mob all
right but I think we have to start with
our newest Fox News contributor Emily
congratulations we're glad that you're a
contributor to Fox News so we'll give
you the first shot of talking about the
president making a decision to address
the nation tomorrow night thank you so
much for small really it's such an honor
to be part of this family you're welcome
I just I think what's important for me
is for viewers to understand what it
would look like if the president
actually declared a national emergency
and what that what trickles down from
that and basically in the 70s this Act
was passed it was post-watergate it was
post-vietnam and the main thing that he
would have to do is cite a specific
emergency
the provision a specific emergency power
right that activates what he's asking
for and so there are hundreds of them by
the way there are hundreds of provisions
under this act and he just has to
specifically cite it and underneath that
he gets extraordinary Authority he can
take land he can seize property he can
restrict travel etc and we are hearing
already from the left and some of those
comments things like well you know we're
gonna take this to court and this is
just like this steel thing and it's not
it's totally separate the only
challengeable aspect would be whether
that's that specificity is it's tied
together right and the other thing that
people should understand is that those
specific provisions
there's monetary associations with it so
if he went under the Immigration Act for
example that caps at 20 million so
really and there's a there's a ton more
options and whatnot but basically a kind
of overview would be cobbling together
the money in the funding and whether
that's an articulable specificity and by
the way it pretty much is because for
example under that Immigration Act all
that needs to happen is for him to cite
the fact that the current resources are
basically being stretched thin that that
they're not keeping up with it so
there's that and then I also think on
the unrepresentative Jeffries comment
about well you know we don't want to
hold the American people hostage any
longer over this medieval I they have
that let's listen to that we'll get you
and Jesse to comment on this because he
wanted to comment too do we have that
montage please we need to actually
reopen the government and stop holding
the American people hostage simply
because Donald Trump wants a medieval
waterwall a fourth century concrete wall
that you can't see through will be a
less effective border barrier let's
spend the citizens money in a smart
fashion not with some fourth century
basically pointless strategy so the
fourth century talking point has gone
out the signal yeah and here's my point
he said we're that that holds us hostage
right now there's the standoff we're
already held hostage we are held hostage
throughout the entire entire nation
right now with everything that is coming
over the southern border and how it
impacts all aspects of the criminal
justice system it's not just the drugs
coming across or migrants seeking asylum
it goes so much deeper than that when we
have what like what's this what's the
currency of all the games riddle e in
these cities it is drugs what our how
our sheriff's prevented how are the the
you know relations between is't cetera
there it's multi layers it is indeed
what do you think about that fourth
century comment
well he's not using leeches at the
southern border security not yet Jesse
yeah just wait I listen a lot of things
are useful that have been used for a
very long time from medieval times
shackles blades men on horseback prisons
shields you know those things are useful
becomes that your favorite some of your
favorite things the president likes to
use the analogy of the wheel the wheel
works overtime and it's because it's
effective just like walls are effective
I don't like how Nadler saying the
president is gonna lie tomorrow night
the president's told the truth on the
caravan from the beginning he said it
was mostly men not a bunch of women and
children the men we're looking for money
not asylum and what happened when the
caravan finally reached the southern
border uptick three hundred percent and
violence perpetrated against the border
agents if anything the president has
compromised and moderated his position
if you look at he's offering out eight
hundred million dollars for humanitarian
situation he's saying now we want to
steal fence the steel fence has been
voted on positively by Democrats in the
past it's environmentally friendly the
water can just trickle through it it
helps the US steel industry as well
people can see through it so they have
visibility on the other side a lot of
these things that the president's doing
is trying to bring that Nancy Pelosi to
the negotiating table if anything Nancy
looks like the ones stuck in the mud but
one I do think that the Democrats seem
vulnerable on that point that they did
vote for secure fencing in the past and
does it really matter if it's steel or
concrete no this whole thing is a
manufactured you know political from
both sides no from the trash Trump is
the one question was they voted in the
past for secure fence yes
in order for border security I mean
unless I mean if the argument is
Democrats don't click here about border
security that's patently false this
whole thing though is striking to me in
that only the only way to understand
since the Trump is playing base tribal
politics most independents don't support
it
obviously most Democrats don't support
it there is no national emergency you
can go back to the midterms there was
remember it we were being invaded oh now
it looks like there was no invasion it
was a bunch of desperate people at the
moment he says oh there are all these
criminals coming over if you watch Fox
News Sunday yesterday Chris Wallace
absolutely dismantle Sarah Huckabee
Sanders on this point there is no
evidence even from Trump's own Justice
Department his own immigration services
so he's doing this for some political
reason and it's not quite clear what it
is except to me to distract from his own
problems with Wall Street going on to a
failure to enact an asylum ban to the
Proms ease has with John Bolton
contradicting him about the pullout well
there's plenty we could talk about but
let's talk stick on this so the
president's going to address the nation
tomorrow night can he address all those
things that want to say for independence
that might not be on yeah I think you
should address the the crux of the the
of the argument of the Democrats when
they're constantly saying walls are
immoral okay that's the whole point
that's kind of like what everybody's
saying oh it's horrible it's immoral
well what about the walls that we
already have then should should we
should we ask Nancy Pelosi about
removing the walls that we already have
on the border because there are walls on
the border that the this stance is so
weak you could blow it over with a
sneeze and and also I know you know want
always keep saying oh it's it's
appealing to the base essentially that's
what politics is is you're appealing to
the people who voted for you and he made
a promise that he was going to build a
wall it might have put him in a corner
it might but he has to actually address
it because no one really addressed it in
this way before
the fact is the Democrats agree with him
on everything and the only reason why
they won't do it it's because it's him
so the bottom line is it's a personal
vendetta and President Trump tomorrow
should talk about the talk about the
wall but also should talk about the
personal vendetta and say look a clearly
the Democrats were for this but they
don't like me so I'm gonna step out of
this I want somebody somebody else to
take charge of this I'll step out of the
room so you guys so I don't want the
credit I will step out here you get the
engineers involved because you just
heard Schumer's say that it's not so
much about the money now it's a fact
they don't have a plan well that's the
step so now you come up with this plan
with the engineers involved it's what
they ask the experts what they need but
I'm gonna step out of it you said you
want to dr. Phil to be the no no no dr.
Drew dr. Phil dr. Dre calling dr.
Frankenstein but I just wanted to say to
you if that's the case if it's just
about ever the way you posed a trump
hatred well how can we had two years of
a Republican majority in the house in
the Senate and Trump in the White House
didn't get done how prompt says the
Mexicans will pay for this wall I don't
see that how about he says the walls
being built and there's no wall you just
keep lying and you guys keep buying no
I'm not buying anything but I will say
this I do love a stalemate and I'll tell
you why because I like slow government
I'm like a slow cooker so I'm okay with
this going on and the thing is and
here's this what here's an interesting
truth what if you through a government
shutdown and nobody came I mean it
really is interesting week we sit here
we go it's day 14 or it's the third week
of harvest I want to hike in the
national parks tomorrow and I can't Bob
really and I really need a good hike you
do I've seen you put on weight thank you
hundred thousand people who don't get
paid plus I guess 40 thousand
contractors those are real people yeah
but the real people that if you look at
employment across the board one it's
been an amazing achievement across the
board we should punish these Pino I'm
not saying I'm saying that there are
some things you get with the pluses and
the minuses and right now Trump this is
a this is a shutdown that's happening
after I hear you and I say Juan doesn't
get paid during the show